[Music]
it was a feel-good story a prep school
with an unconventional approach that
managed to open the doors of higher
education for its students but behind
the school's own doors things might not
have been what they seemed Manuel
Bojorquez has the story these viral
videos showing students being accepted
to elite colleges helped put Louisiana's
TN Landry college prep school on the map
the school boasted it helped provide
underprivileged African American kids
opportunities they typically wouldn't
have gotten and it made national
headlines founder Michael Landry spoke
with Omar Villafranca for CBS this
morning last year when my wife and I
started to school people laughed at us
however Landry's unconventional approach
no traditional teachers textbooks or
homework also caught one Yale trustees
attention I called the Dean of
undergraduate admissions at Yale and I
said I either just saw a hero or a
complete fraud now people are crying
foul a New York Times investigation
which included interviews with current
and former students revealed allegations
of doctored college applications and
falsified transcripts at the hands of
Landry and his wife Tracy CBS News has
also learned of allegations that Michael
Landry's tough style extended to mental
and physical abuse including making
students kneel on rice rocks or hot
pavement on a Lewis was a student there
[Music]
her mother Latasha Lewis pulled her and
her two other children out of the school
do feel betrayed I saw the videos and I
wanted exactly what I saw in the video
is for my children
attorney Ashley McFarland represents the
Lewis's and several other families these
kids were mentally emotionally severely
affected by their experience at team
Landry and continues to be so the
Landry's denied all the allegations to
the Times and declined an interview with
CBS News the attorney representing some
of the families says on top of the
roughly $600 a month in tuition they pay
it at the school some parents are now
having to pay tutors to help their
children catch up for CBS
morning Saturday I'm Manuel Bojorquez if
this is true it is so incredibly
damaging to all the schools out there
that have similar programs for
under-represented kids it's so damaging
to those students who has you heard
meeting tutors now you're now escaped
behind yourself being where you need to
be its breaks my heart
yep it is heartbreaking